so you are fascinating to me because
you've led a very different life than a
lot of modern women in this and you've
been very open about that in the sense
that you married an older guy you your
prescription for happiness for women for
for those who are seeking you know to
want to be a housewife who want to do
all that your prescription is
antithetical to what is preached in 2022
Society feminists monoramous can't stand
you I mean I'm just going to be honest
they don't like you and they don't like
you for many reasons we're going to talk
about why but you did this interview
um with the Huffington Post they
actually wrote an article about you but
they asked you to weigh in so credit to
them on that they don't always do that
sometimes they just write it and you're
like oh did I say that no I didn't
and people responded to this pretty
vigorously first I want to pull up what
you said in a tweet that drove them mad
and this has driven by the way people
the left wing lost their minds on this
and I say the left wing is it's mostly
left wing can you pull up that twit that
tweet from
I don't know champagne Eureka
yeah okay so this is you this is video
and look he says they really got mad in
the comment because they did the
comments were like
I mean crazy
this is what she said she was this is
just pearly that was talking to you
right because on her Tick Tock that the
left Essence bombed so she is no longer
on she's on her her fourth Tick Tock
account she's not stopping anytime soon
so so she asks you about your situation
your marriage we can see a beautiful
ring on your finger and you're married
your hat you seem happy okay
Congratulations by the way on that
um so let's let's play this for the
audience
okay Ally show me your ring oh here now
tell me what you do for a living
oh I love my husband and how did you how
did you get that awesome job well I
became a better human being and I became
feminine and also shocking submissive so
that was the secret so what are your
tips to women that want to be a
housewife
to embrace it it's an actual job you
just can't get it in the public or
private sector like you need you need a
man to hire you for it but that's okay
because if you think about it you submit
to your boss who makes you clean stupid
shelves at your retail job right like
wouldn't it be better if you were
cleaning your own shows at home you know
what I mean in your in your boss wants
to sleep with you in a good way in a
good way and where where do you meet
these men well I think women should work
for the men that they want to pursue I
know that sounds crazy but it's really
easy so if you think about it like you
want a lawyer right so then you should
be a paralegal or if you want a dentist
then you should be a dental hygienist
but these are considered I guess high
high value status prevent professions
but I think that's a really good model
that not enough women utilize because
women will bully the woman who is the
secretary that marries the doctor okay
but who has the last laugh like her in
her mcmansion with her husband who's hot
and the babies like that's okay so
feminist ads exploding everywhere
um do you do you understand why this got
under the skin of modern feminists oh
well yes they they can't decide if they
want to talk about romance in terms of
capitalism or if they want to talk about
romance like in a traditionally artistic
way so they're kind of torn between that
and to me I mean I I think it can be
both I think there's logistical aspects
to romance there's also very cringe to
watch oh my goodness like why is it
cringe for you to watch it oh my and
it's not what I expected to go viral for
because I was just playing around with
pearl in the back of an Uber right in
the back of an Uber and I think the
funny thing about it is too I wore that
wojak dress on accident I actually love
that dress it was 16 from Old Navy and
then oh in the background I think that
song if you listen to the lyrics I think
it's uh I can't recall but it says like
pretty pretty face bad character so
everything was just very right about
that moment but yes do you stand by what
you said in that clip though yeah
absolutely I mean factually it's girl
game women need to wake up y'all are
dating aimlessly like how about put some
respect on my name you're welcome you're
welcome it's fine to hit on your doctor
at your annual checkup like what do you
have to lose so but let me ask you this
word submissive because I think just
having grown up in New York City my
whole life I was surrounded by I went to
Columbia I was like the left was just
everywhere and modern feminism was it's
just like coming through everyone's
pores there so when I see this I still
have the receptors like I personally
don't share a lot of their views uh
their World Views but I have the
receptors where I know oh that's going
to get them oh that's the word
submissive immediately will drive them
crazy when you say that word what do you
how what does that look like in a home
in terms of like how does that play out
a submissive role
well for my marriage Dynamic I give my
husband Authority with responsibility I
think Rolo talks about this where men
are just given responsibility without
Authority and that's essentially slavery
but I'm okay and I'm comfortable with
that so there's a lot of things that go
on where my husband will have the final
word and I I Look to Him for guidance
because he can think about ways to
protect me that might not even be on my
mind so I like to have that sounding
board and I mean I've been alive the
whole time I've been married so I think
he's doing a good job does that mean
that you don't have a say like
ultimately because what it what it what
they Envision when they critique you is
like almost like having another dad
they're like oh well I already have a
dad I don't need another dad I don't
want to be put in my place they want you
know they say well does the woman have a
voice in those situations so does that
mean that you no longer have a voice or
does that ultimately mean that like are
you not part of the decision-making
process if you're submissive or are you
part of it but ultimately saying you get
the final State tell me like what that
looks like in terms of your husband
decides that it's time to move does he
come to you and say uh hey this is what
I'm thinking about what do you think or
is it we're moving here end of story
what does submissive mean so submissive
it depends on who you're asking because
when people hear submissive they think
Kink which obviously is just you know a
way to pervert conventional gender roles
so a if you're living in that Kink
Dynamic for my understanding from the
women that I've talked to yes whatever
the man says goes but they're they are
basically agreeing to be a submissive to
a dominant and that's a completely
different thing that does not exist in
my life I do not want to know anything
about it unfortunately I have come to
find out so for myself and my marriage
it's really just letting a man be a man
I I don't I don't understand what's the
point of you know arguing with him
because if we have to move it's probably
for a reason and he probably thinks that
it's a good idea he is going to get my
input though and those things have
happened as well because we're we're
military and so there's some career
opportunities that come up and he says
hey you know I can pursue this but this
is what might happen what do you think
and if we make decisions based off of
that but it your husband's not going to
be perfect so if you do let your husband
lead your marriage and he makes a
mistake you know he takes the
responsibility and accountability for
that yes but it's not the end of the
world because how many times do we make
mistakes as wives right has the world
ended yet no I'm sure I made a mistake
this morning like who knows do you
understand like the language of because
you made a You made an analogy in there
about having a boss and having a husband
that's going to drive people nuts too
because obviously they're like well I
don't want my husband to be my boss and
they often will use the word and I've
taken heat for using the word partner
because you know and not to say I'm
you're not in a marriage but a
partnership feels like everyone comes to
the table and kind of works through for
example and the way it works in my house
and I always say is that
my husband will say hey this is going on
what do you think about this these are
the options we have I win and he always
feels like I want your input because I
want us both to be happy in the
decisions that we make so we really make
these decisions together I wouldn't be
comfortable in a situation where I felt
like my husband was a boss because I can
go to work and get that or I can you
know I don't even want that at work
that's why I'm doing a partnership at
work but there has to be a distinction
for some women between a boss employee
Dynamic and a marriage now you may feel
differently you may be really
comfortable with that but just
articulate from me a little bit about
what you meant with the analogy to a
boss because I think that's really
interesting
I would say it's partly that feminist
thing where you can work and be a boss
babe and if you're you're actual boss
your employer asks you to get something
done out of nowhere during the work day
that you weren't expecting you might be
a little bit disgruntled but you say
okay and you'll get it done because it's
the person that's signing your paycheck
right so if you're a stay-at-home wife
and if something comes up hey babe I'm
you get this earring done a lot of women
will push back against their husbands
well that wasn't in my schedule well
there's that in the third and it's crazy
to think about it because it's not free
labor I know people like to say that
it's free labor it's absolutely not so
why is it okay if your employer asks you
to get something done around the house
but if your husband does then you've got
hell to pay but for myself too it's just
I've always been a really excellent
worker that's what happens to high IQ
girls when they go to public school
education they teach you how to be a
good worker which I have lots of
thoughts and opinions about public
school my kids aren't going but that's
the way that I thought about it because
I want to take pride in my work I was in
the military I was in the military I
made E5 in three years there's a 60
whiskey so a combat medic specialist so
I I just like you know the prestige I
guess of having a job right and so to me
when I think about being a housewife I'm
like yes like I'm gonna I'm Gonna Make
this House great I'm gonna make this
meal great I want to be employee of the
month every month my perspective and it
probably is because I'm an American
woman but that's where it's coming from
and that is also the language that a lot
of women understand right now because we
are ingrained in capitalism and I don't
have a problem with capitalism
capitalism actually enables Housewives
to exist so shout out to that but yeah
it's a lot of women out there that they
would rather die than stay home I'm like
What's the nightmare I mean we have so
many machines and you can work from home
like say less like sign me up if you
want to watch the full episode you're
going to click right here and if you
want to ask me a question one on one you
want to do a one-on-one face time with a
group of your friends whatever you want
you need to download manect right now
click right here and let's get talking
foreign
[Music]